نشاهد صور مباشره بالفعل عبد الحفيظ يتحدث
عن اغلاق جميع المنافذ همم في حي اا النبي
يعقوب او النبي يعقوب في القدس بعد اطلاق
النار هذه صور على ما يبدو كما نتابع
لسياره المنفذ كما قال عبد الحفيظ قبل
قليل انه منفذ الهجوم الذي قام الامن
الاسرائيلي بتصفيته كان يقول سياره قام
بالخروج منها وتنفيذ اذا عمليه اطلاق
النار التي اودت بحياه سبعه مستطيل
اسرائيليين حتى الان واا اصابه 10 على
الاقل همم فيما يبدو ان هذه هي سياره
المهاجم
صور مباشره اذا المشاهدين مباشره من نبي
يعقوب شرقيه القدس بعد هذه العمليه كما
تشاهدون اثار الرصاص كذلك على زجاج
الامامي للسياره
[موسيقى]
صحيفه جنب بوست كما نقلت قبل قليل انه تم
تحيد المهاجم الذي قام بقتل ااا سبعه
اسرائيليين على الاقل مراسلنا تحدث عن
وصول المهاجم الى ساحه كنيس يهودي في حي
النبي يعقوب في القدس والامن الاسرائيلي
كما تتابعون الان يغلق جميع منافذ القدس
بعد هذه العمليه التي تاتي غادتها التصعيد
الاسرائيلي الكبير في جنين في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه همم والذي اودى بحياه تسعه
فلسطينيين كذلك الان كما